[Music]
when I was a kid looking at the stars I
really always wondered you know how did
we get here and are we alone my name is
Bethany Elmen I'm a professor of
planetary science at Caltech and
research scientist at the NASA Jet
Propulsion Laboratory I remember when I
was six I declared that I wanted to be
an astrophysicist like Stephen Hawking
and I'm not an astrophysicist but I am
an explorer an explorer of planets of
asteroids and I really enjoy the unknown
in space exploration we're going places
that really no one has gone before and
it's one of the few types of science
where you can do that our solar system
is about four-and-a-half billion years
old and asteroids formed within the
first few million years that the solar
system existed asteroids are mostly
metal and rock and ice and are thought
to be the shattered remnants of planets
there are these banked vaults full of
information about what conditions were
like early in the solar system as
planets were forming what we're looking
at here is the largest asteroid in the
asteroid belt and we're able to have
this amazing view because of the Dawn
spacecraft mission which orbited series
for several years they midgets are t10
the dawn mission was a spacecraft that
was launched in 2007 and it was designed
to study series which is the largest
asteroid in the asteroid belt and it's
actually not just an asteroid it's a
dwarf planet
[Music]
one of the most fascinating things about
series that we discovered is it wasn't a
uniform gray some parts of the surface
had these amazing brighter spots here
you can see one of them coming out of
the crater this was totally unexpected
one of the fun parts of being a
planetary scientist and especially my
job is that I have a laboratory where we
get to measure the spectroscopic
signatures of rocks and minerals every
material has a characteristic way that
it reflects light we can call this a
spectral signature and so one of the
things that we can do is here on earth
we can measure the spectral signatures
of all sorts of materials that we know
exactly what they are and then we can
compare those signatures to the
reflected light that we get from
asteroids to figure out what those
objects are made of now on Ceres we
basically repeat the measurement but our
spacecraft is the sensor instead of my
lab instrument and the source instead of
a halogen light in the lab is the Sun
and so by comparing those materials in
the lab to the materials that we see on
other planets that's how we know what
planets and asteroids are made of when
we looked at the data we found that
these bright spots were actually made of
salts and these salts were being pulled
up by impacts so salts underneath the
surface of Ceres what did that mean
that meant that there were salty waters
underneath series at some period of time
maybe even a salty ocean deep
underground what passed underground
waters tells us on series is that series
was once wet and because other asteroids
are like series water rich that tells us
that some of the asteroids that were
hitting earth early in its history
we're probably delivering some of the
water that's found on our planet today
one of the key questions about asteroids
is did they play any role in the origin
of life
asteroids brought water and carbon some
of the most important ingredients for
life to our planet very early in its
history did they help make Earth this
amazing habitable place it is today we
don't fully know the answer we think
they played a role but that's one of the
things we're trying really hard to
figure out right now
[Music]
so these are some of the reasons that I
explore is curiosity and a desire to
learn things that no one yet knows
[Music]
[Music]